I'm not sure I understand people pay you
to kidnap for the simulated experience
of high-stakes abduction yes case file
for 0-2 subjects an insane Blaire
subject has requested a surprise
scenario she won't know when it's coming
aware Wow listen Anna this can go very
smoothly for you or very difficult Lea
what she's good
authorities are still searching today
for a Hollywood Hills woman huh I'm
gonna need some answers there you told
you remember you think you're treading
very dangerous waters here are some very
serious shop yelling in my face you know
what this is you called me on the phone
paid for this yours was a special case
let me guess ray you got carried away
[Music]
are you Raymond Moody they're here about
a lady went missing last night isn't a
little early to open a missing-persons
investigation I watch a lot of cop shows
I think you like tying people
[Music]
I'm gonna have times out of 10 I'm
really not a bad person
[Music]
similarly have a good weekend community
it's not a real gun what it's not a real
gun is just a pellet gun oh oh
[Music]
you